[Musique]
bonsoir nouvelle semaine d'information
locale sur tv 78 bienvenue dans cette
édition spéciale du lundi 27 avril
le point pour commencer sur la situation
sanitaire lié aux coronavirus dans les
yvelines ce week-end trois décès
supplémentaires sont survenus ce qui
porte à 4 101 le nombre de morts dans
les hôpitaux du département hier
dimanche après trois journées
consécutives de baisse les
hospitalisations sont repartis en légère
hausse
elles s'établissent à 835 sur le
territoire 122 personnes était en
réanimation
et puis 1323 c'est le nombre de patients
guéris du coc vite 19 dans les yvelines
et qui ont pu retourner à leur domicile
parmi les victimes du coc vie 19 on a
appris samedi la disparition du docteur
jacques fribourg médecin urgentiste
ancien chef des urgences de l'hôpital
privé de trappes service qu'il avait
fondé et où il avait passé une grande
partie de sa carrière et jacques
fribourg était à la retraite depuis
septembre dernier mais officiait comme
bénévole au salut et à la croix-rouge
diw
une disparition qui a largement ému et
fait réagir parmi confrères médecins et
luche notamment aurélien rousseau
directeur général et de l'agencé
régionale de santé d'ile-de-france qui
se souvient d'un homme bon connus et
reconnus oeuvrant sans relâche au
service des yvelinois la croix rouge des
yvelines justement où à chaque fribourg
exerçait bénévolement comme médecin
territoriale est en deuil
elle arbore d'ailleurs à un bandeau noir
sur son logo enfin les responsables
politiques du département ont également
tenu à présenter leurs condoléances à
commencer par le préfet des yvelines
jean jacques brot qui a exprimé sa
grande émotion et sa profonde tristesse
enfin condoléances également de pierre
bédier président du conseil
départemental des yvelines qui a tenu à
affirmer sa reconnaissance à tous les
soignants heavy noah qui paient un lourd
tribut dans cette lutte contre le
coronavirus 42e jour de confinement il
sera bientôt question de déconfinement
comment les maires s'organise-t-il
durant cette période de la gestion des
services publics en période d'urgence
sanitaire à la préparation de la
réouverture des écoles témoignage
aujourd'hui du maire de guyancourt
françois morton entretien mené par
wilfrid richy
nous sommes avec françois morton à
présent bonjour à vous bonjour mr de
guyancourt nous allons voir comment
votre ville gère cette période de
confinement quels sont les services déjà
les services municipaux qui fonctionne
aujourd'hui et depuis le 17 mars
alors depuis le début du confinement en
fait nous avons fait le choix de
conserver une permanence un accueil
physique tous les matins de 9h à 11h
pour les situations d'urgence et bien
évidemment l'ensemble des habitants peut
continuer à contacter les services de la
ville au numéro du standard circuits
habituels de la vie mais on a plutôt en
ce sens un service d'astreinte a
effectivement on adaptera les personnels
doivent intervenir en fonction des
problématiques rencontrées
on note aussi qu' en élan de solidarité
partout qui s'est manifesté c'est le cas
aussi pour l'aiguillon courtoise élégant
courtois ya une plate forme que vous
avez lancé pour recenser un petit peu
tout ça alors cette pâle cette
plateforme s appelle le soyons
solidaires alors elle est assez simple
d'utilisation en fait hein c'est à dire
que elle met en lien les besoins les
réponses à ces besoins
vous pouvez avoir un certain nombre
besoin de besoins du type je ne peux pas
imprimer une attestation de sortie par
exemple ou alors j'ai des difficultés à
les faire mes courses et de l'autre côté
vous avez des habitants qui se proposent
pour effectivement répondre à ses
besoins et donc cette plateforme mais
tout simplement les gens en contact
on peut voir aussi que donc la
solidarité s'exprime et via votre site
internet vous avez décidé chaque jour de
relayer aussi des personnalités un petit
peu qui se démarquent
oui c'est vrai que c'est important aussi
de mettre du positif période un petit
peu morose j'ai envie de dire et donc
c'est important de pouvoir mettre en
lumière un certain nombre d'acteurs et
on va poursuivre ce système parce que
c'est vraiment important alors sur la
page facebook aussi on met du positif ce
qui est important c'est par exemple
comment rendre cette morosité au travers
va vous les connaissez aussi à toutes
ces vidéos humoristiques ou alors
comment faire du sport ou comment
effectivement faire de la danse faire
des choses comme ça que vous pouvez
retrouver tout à fait facilement soit
sur le site de la ville soit sur la page
fais ça c'est pour tout l'aspect positif
est qu'il faut relayer sur l'aspect
aussi des des contraintes il ya un
confinement à faire respecter la police
municipale y veille comment le
services municipaux travail est ce que
ce confinement aussi est globalement
respecté on l'a entendu il ya toujours
des rappels un petit peu qu'il faut
faire de temps en temps alors la très
grande majorité je le dis très
clairement la très grande majorité des
guyancourt toi respecte parfaitement ce
confinement et on n'est pas à l'abri de
rencontrer une toute petite minorité de
personnes soit qui n'ont pas forcément
bien conquis les consignes au démarrage
et il était important de les rappeler au
travers de nos canaux de communication
bien évidemment ou qui ne souhaite pas
certain nombre de fois respectée c'est
cette période de confinement et la
police municipale ou toujours en
articulation avec la police nationale
parce que telle est notre projet depuis
toujours admis en cours c'est cette
articulation avec la police nationale et
est amené bien évidemment à verbaliser
et la police municipale est en
permanence dans les rues de la ville
après six semaines les choses se sont
mis en place non il faut penser aux
déconfinement aussi en tout cas au début
de déconfinement qui devrait intervenir
autour du du 11 mai aujourd'hui vous
avez des discussions avec les services
de l'état aujourd'hui vous réfléchissez
sur la réouverture des écoles qui les
écoles la gestion des écoles qui fait
partie des prérogatives des meilleurs
justement alors d'une manière plus
globale depuis le début du confinement
j'ai envie de dire on pas qu'on fout
complètement des continents depuis début
du confinement je précise
on a toujours été en relation avec nos
acteurs institutionnels traditionnels
que ce soit le préfet la région
ile-de-france de département
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines bien évidemment et c'est grâce
d'ailleurs à ce partenariat qui
fonctionne plutôt bien que nous avons pu
nous procurer un certain nombre de
matériels jeu constamment aux masques
chirurgicaux par exemple ont été
distribués aux professionnels de santé
le gel hydroalcoolique nous avons puisé
dans nos propres commandes réserve pour
toujours privilégier ces professionnels
de santé et puis effectivement nous
sommes en discussion alors
il est temps maintenant de passer à une
nouvelle phase vous l'avez dit c'est
celle de l'anticipation du déconfinement
je pense qu'il faut arrêter de subir les
déclarations les unes après les autres
et de s'adapter au fur et à mesure mais
de commencer un travail de son
d'anticipation de ceux des compliments
donc on suit de près et effectivement ce
que peut dire le président de la
république le premier ministre bien
entendu je suis parfois en décalé le
ministre de l'éducation nationale mais
c'est une autre problème est
effectivement on est sur cette
anticipation du déconfinement mais vous
voyez bien que la réouverture des écoles
par exemple entraîne en cascade un
certain nombre de réouverture de service
quid du périscolaire par exemple d
accueil de loisirs quand seuls les
accueils du matin les accueils du soir
tout cela sera géré par les mairies
après la vouvoie vous êtes en train de
voir comment vous organisez pour ça
alors on est obligé de commencer à y
réfléchir
voilà c'est j'ai envie de te dire comme
ça et c'est pour ça que nous avons un
certain nombre de réunions de travail
avec les directeurs de la ville en
charge de tous ces secteurs on voit
comment le moment venu on va pouvoir
mettre en pratique effectivement ces
diverses ouvertures
sachant que nous ne sommes pas naïfs et
que comme l'a dit d'ailleurs le premier
ministre tout ne va pas réouvrir du jour
au lendemain bien évidemment les
cantines pourrait ouvrir par exemple ce
serait ce sera faisable ça serait cool
sur quoi sur une base de volontariat
aussi peut-être du personnel alors
depuis le début du décompte du
confinement pardon nous accueillons déjà
un certain nombre d'enfants qui sont les
enfants des professionnels de santé de
sécurité
nous avons été une des premières
communes à tout de suite accueillir
d'ailleurs les enfants des
professionnels des métiers de la
sécurité car il était important de
pouvoir les prendre en charge et donc
dans ce cadre les demi-pensions est déjà
assurée l'organe évidemment s'il ya une
reprise de l'école il faut de toute
façon songer à une reprise des temps de
demi pension et des temps j'ai envie de
dire quel scolaire d'une manière plus
globale il ya la question des masques
aussi comment se passe la gestion des
masses qu'est ce que vous faites des
stocks vous allez en distribuant ici
berlaimont
la réponse est oui c'est à dire qu'il
est hors de question d'attendre
effectivement une dotation
potentiel qui pourrait arriver de l'état
c'est à dire que nous devons être
responsables et nous avons déjà en ce
sens passé des commandes pour des
masques chirurgicaux mais également par
des masques tissu lavable et
réutilisable
il y aura des distributions à la
population aussi dans certaines communes
ce sera le cas est ce que ce sera le cas
à guyancourt
ce sera le cas guyancourt bien
évidemment j'ai envie de dire que pour
l'instant je suis dans l'incapacité je
dis très clairement d'annoncer des
délais je souhaite que toutes ces
masques alors les masques chirurgicaux
g je suis plutôt confiant sur cette
arrivée avant le 11 mai sur les masques
d'issue je pense qu'on sera à peu près
dans la période
merci beaucoup françois morton maire de
guyancourt d'avoir été en ligne avec
nous pour faire ce point sur la
situation actuellement et puis sur cette
réflexion qui est plus que s'engage
aujourd'hui sur le déconfinement merci à
vous merci rang réfléchir ensemble à des
solutions pour lutter et vaincre le coc
u19 le but du défi à caton qui s'est
déroulé partout sur le continent à
l'initiative de la commission européenne
à l'opération et est ouverte à toutes
les bonnes volontés plus de quinze mille
personnes ont ainsi pu collaborer à
distance est la région ile de france et
est partenaire du haka ton en y prenant
part également et en coachant certains
projets qui ont émergé et le bilan est
assez positif écouté il y a eu 1500
projets je crois d'autres fois jeune et
c'est d'ailleurs une bonne nouvelle en
soi c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de
créativité beaucoup d envie
les projets ils sont très bizarre un peu
toujours suivi six projets en
particulier il ya des bonnes idées à la
fois pour le court terme pour le long
terme et un certain nombre de projets
qui tournait autour de comment est-ce
qu'on peut mieux comprendre les
phénomènes qui se passe à partir de la
donne et comment le virus se répand
comment est ce qu'on arrive à avoir des
actions les plus efficaces pour lutter
contre la propagation du virus
il y à un certain nombre de projets qui
tournait autour d'eux comment est ce
qu'on va pouvoir ré ouvrir les lieux de
notre activité quotidienne que ce soit
les commerces dans leur ensemble les
lieux de divertissement et puis par
ailleurs d'autres projets par exemple
sur bas comment est ce qu'on va pouvoir
petit à petit réouvrir les frontières
entre nos pays il ya eu pas mal
d'initiatives
tron prometteuses sur des passeports des
certifications des mesures barrières au
niveau des frontières enfin voilà
beaucoup de créativité encore une fois
les projets transmis vont être étudiées
par la commission européenne cette
semaine les lauréats connu le 1er mai
est depuis le 6 avril une trentaine de
jeunes confiés à l'aide sociale à
l'enfance passe quelques jours au
château de jambville un moyen de mieux
supporter le confinement
au programme des activités nature tout
en respectant bien sûr les règles
sanitaires
aurélie rond et patrick jacques de
dixmude habituellement le château de
jambville accueille tout au long de
l'année des classes vertes ou encore des
séminaires fermés en raison de la crise
sanitaire l'établissement a obtenu une
dérogation de la préfecture pour ainsi
permettre aux jeunes de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance de se mettre au vert c'était
compliqué de pouvoir confiné des enfants
qui ont des parcours complexe et du coup
se confinant peut faire écho à leur
propre histoire
l'idée ça a été proposé une petite
parenthèse verdoyante l'a appelé un peu
comme ça pour les pour des groupes
d'enfants de différents établissements
profiter des espaces verts tout en
respectant les règles sanitaires en
vigueur
chaque semaine trois groupes de dix
jeunes des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine sont sur le site mais ne
se côtoient pas ici pas de télévision ni
de wifi
il n'y a pas forcément de journée type
on voit en fonction aussi des besoins
des enfants ce qu'ils ont besoin de
faire dans la journée six ans plus
besoin de marcher de se défouler et il y
a de quoi faire pas moins de 52 ha
entoure le château
les familles peuvent aller vivre dans le
parc sans risque et justes en croisant
des animaux écureuils faisant et autres
bestioles qui sont en train de
s'épanouir dans le parc on a cette
sécurité de se dire balesi fallait faire
un tour de vélo et ils savent revenir
donc seul avantage qu'on a deux de
pouvoir les laisser à leurs occupations
librement sans qu'on soit sur leur dos
parmi les activités nature proposer la
découverte des abeilles ou encore la
préparation de repas au coin du feu
celui qui a participé à un séjour
précédent a pu revenir avec les
histoires avec ce qu'ils avaient vécu
avec ce qu'ils avaient partagé
du coup ils sont impatients en fait
chaque jour
ils attendent avec impatience de pouvoir
partir et ils attendent leurs dates et
leur départ donc tous les 7 9 ans ont
déjà leurs valises de près depuis deux
jours
ouais ça se répand en fait à l'intérieur
du centre comme étant un lieu agréable
où on passe des bons moments à la fois
avec les adultes et à la fois avec les
camarades du groupe
ces séjours d'aération doivent se
poursuivre jusqu'au 11 n'ont guère
dimanche 26 avril c'était la journée du
souvenir des victimes de la déportation
une date pour se souvenir et honoré
c'est 700 mille femmes hommes et enfants
enfermés dans les camps de la mort
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale cette
année c'était d'ailleurs le 75e
anniversaire de la libération des camps
de concentration mais pas de cérémonie
hier pour autant en raison des mesures
sanitaires et du confinement
on parle de cette date anniversaire avec
viviane bouttier bonsoir bonsoir
présidente des amis de la fondation pour
la mémoire de la déportation des
yvelines et également avec nous et hervé
fleury bonsoir bonsoir vous vous êtes
donc fils et petit fils de déporté
vice-président également de
l'association des déportés internés et
familles des disparus des yvelines aux
premières questions avoue hervé fleury
comment pouvait-on honorer ce jour
malgré l'absence de cérémonie
comment pouvait-on se se souvenir de ces
femmes hommes et enfants qui sont qui
ont été enfermés dans ces camps de
concentration mais je crois que le
meilleur moyen c'était de revivre dans
nos familles la mémoire de ceux qui ont
vécu cette période terrible cette
déportation soit une déportation raciale
soit une déportation en politique comme
ce fut le cas dans ma famille donc
ressortir les photos prendre un temps de
silence
en regardant ces photos en écoutant le
chant des marais qui est l'hymne des
déportés avoir un temple d'intériorité
pour être en lien avec eux et se penser
à tout ce qu'ils ont fait pour que nous
soyons aujourd'hui libres dans notre
confinement et viviane boussier alors
vos associations respectives ont appelé
les
les maires des communes des yvelines
malgré cette absence de cérémonie a tout
de même se mobiliser même de manière
symbolique pour honorer ce jour c'est ça
exactement
il était convenu que dans la mesure où
on pouvait chaque président de
délégation donc dans chaque départements
envoyé une lettre au maire le disons
leur rappelant l'importance de ces
journées leur rappelant que c'était
comme le dit monsieur fleury 1075 le 75e
anniversaire donc j'avais besoin quand
même d'être un petit peu mis en valeur
et pour sensibiliser bain de faire selon
la façon qu'ils le voulaient a rappelle
rappelle alors alors d'administrer un
dépôt de gerbe à 10 points chacun
faisant ce qu'ils voulaient mais l'idée
était de me le dit monsieur fleuri de
montrer l'importance de cette journée à
la fois comme tous les ans depuis 1954
mais aussi pour l'anniversaire
est-ce qu'il ya beaucoup de maires des
divines qui vous ont fait un retour
positif qui vous ont assuré deux de
leurs engagements sur sur cette journée
beaucoup je ne ferai pas de statistiques
mais il ya eu des retours oui certains
disant qu'il ne le ferait avec le 8 mai
de façon à enfumer les deux peut-être
pour des questions toutes simples
administration et de vidéos ce qui peut
se comprendre aussi
mais il ya eu des retours y compris j'ai
eu des photos de merrill ayant des
projets soit le maire soit des adjoints
afin dé selon le cas une gerbe au pied
du monument et peut-être un cas
particulier hervé fleury voûte y est élu
dans la ville de versailles qu'est ce
qui a été fait justement dans cette
ville de versailles pour cette journée
alors au monument aux morts de la ville
de versailles qui est chef lieu du
département il y a le recueil des
cendres de déportés de
une dizaine de camps et devant cette
plaque mémoriale il y a il a été déposée
deux vasques de fleurs par les services
de la ville à la demande du maire qui
lui-même a fait un petit message vidéo
et mallet s'est aussi exprimée par un
message vidéo
l'appel recueillant pour ce 75e
anniversaire de la libération des camps
et ce 75e anniversaire viviane dossier
devait être aussi l'occasion de publier
le travail sur lequel vous avez donc
oeuvré pendant cinq ans et un travail
sur un mémorial des déportés des
yvelines qui recense actuellement 1000
14 ans oui c'est ça en fait pour le 70e
anniversaire je fais pas l'erreur
on avait convenu de revoir le mémorial
de chaque département est en fait une
déclinaison départementale du mémorial
national de la fondation vraiment la
déportation et donc on a travaillé
pendant cinq ans et on a retrouvé des
noms des déportés sans distinction que
ce soit aussi bien des portes et qu'on
appelle résistants politique politiques
n'ayant aucune connotation politique ce
sont les résistants étaient opposés au
nazisme et ou bien de gigant soit juif
et on nous sommes partis environ à deux
chiffres six ans non il y a cinq ans et
nous en sommes aujourd'hui à 1020 parce
que depuis que tous les dix ans la
retrouver dire que et c'est un peu comme
une pelote de file
quand on commence à dérouler on retrouve
d'autres noms etc
les deux critères étant il faut bien que
en ce afin qu'on sache et de critères si
je peux dire pour le mettre dans le
mémorial des yvelines est encore dans
tous les départements
1 tous les départements de france le
fonds est en soi la naissance dans les
yvelines soit l'arrestation dans les
yvelines
ce qui veut dire qu'il ya forcément des
déportés qui vivent 1
un versailles mais qu'il s'en va à
versailles dans les yvelines mais qu'ils
sont pas nues dans les yvelines
julien qui ont été arrêtés pour un tas
de raisons
en dehors donc qui ne sont pas sur le
mémorial
mais comme chaque département le fait
ils seront dans un autre mémorial l'idée
étant d'un mémorial national pour
retrouver une impression
le mot de la fin et vous hervé fleury
vous qui êtes fils petit fils de déporté
pourquoi à l'heure où les derniers
témoins disparaissent aussi peu à peu il
n'y a pas forcément ces derniers témoins
de cette période il faut continuer tout
de même ce devoir de mémoire continue de
se souvenir pourquoi c'est important
pourquoi cette importance parce que nos
parents et nos grands parents nous ont
montré leur amour de la france et se
chante engagé pour qu'un jour nous
retrouvions pour qu'un jouet retrouvions
pardon je bafouille et c'est l'émotion
la liberté et cette liberté
ils l'ont payé très cher par la
déportation en s'engageant aux côtés les
alliés pour libérer la france
ça c'est la première chose et la
deuxième chose donc la première chose
l'amour du pays
et la deuxième chose c'est que nous
devons travailler toutes les
associations et au sens vraiment très
large du monde associatif pour défendre
la dignité de l'homme
parce que sans cesse la dignité de
l'homme est remise en cause
il n'y a qu'à voir ce qui se passe
partout dans le monde donc nous les
enfants nous sommes porteurs de cette
espèce de mission de travailler pour la
défense de la dignité de l'homme
merci pour ce message et merci d'avoir
été avec nous hervé fleury a dit jan bos
et merci à vous merci et à bientôt
alors que les transports s'organise en
ce moment pour une reprise progressive
du trafic en vue du déconfinement 50 ans
neeve il encourage à la pratique du vélo
pour ses déplacements au quotidien pour
ce faire l'agglomération a rouvert
depuis à ce lundi la vélostation situe
en gare sncf à montigny le bretonneux
tous les services reprennent location
réparation de vélos et nouveaux
abonnements il faut simplement prendre
rendez vous avant de se déplacer pour
éviter les déplacements inutiles tous
les abonnements en cours sont prolongées
et gratuitement
c'est la fin de cette édition spéciale
merci de l'avoir suivi quelques images
pour se quitter de cette distribution
opéré par les forains de france au
centre hospitalier de poissy
ils ont remis hier quelques 1500
douceurs sucrées au personnel pomme
d'amour crêpes gaufres ou encore
barbapapa leur façon de remercier toutes
les forces engagées dans la lutte contre
le coc vite 19
restez chez vous et très belle soirée
sur tv 78
[Musique]